welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz today I'm
in Manchester I delighted to be joined
by Indy Paul who is one of the
cofounders of Oakwell Hampton who are a
specialist IT digital and tech sales
agency with offices in Manchester and
currently sitting at 23 heads with some
new people joining soon as well
yep you're saying so been looking
forward to this mate Paul think people
would definitely interested to hear
about the indie journey right so we're
always like to start on this podcast is
how did Indy enter the world of their
recruitment bizarrely really finished
you went to uni in Lancaster did
economics had all the intentions of
trying to be a trader in London and then
kind of last minute thought no I'm a
northern boys they yesterday the north
I'm from Portis field originally and
then yeah Lancaster and then then down
into Manchester but yeah it was never
even knew a recruitment was really I
worked packing mops during the summer
holidays while I was at college and uni
and stuff by leader mops for like Tempe
and our estimates to be where he was and
the only thing I knew about recruitment
was going through a high street who
managed to get that job
so CV on job board so you didn't you
haven't done sales I've done a bit of
sales at uni like I've done a year in
industry I'd worked in retail okay that
kind of thing but I just didn't know
what recruitment was off and then I got
a call from the internal recruitment
team at s3 Parveen who was the wife of
King I think she had told me that story
actually I thought for you is that
there's a short talk there and she said
yes she mentioned yeah she's
representing me to her husband yeah I
remember coming down to munch differ
first interview I know I literally no
idea or I was obviously done my research
on it but still wasn't she no possession
just just like candidates as clients
how'd you put them together where did
you get the jobs at no nothing like that
but just there's a massive buzz when I
remember walking onto the floor and I
was like that's that's cool yeah it was
seem like that sort of trade they're
sort of tight it was busy yeah really
[ __ ] I'm sure you visualize when he was
like economics trade yeah absolutely
yeah and then you know sage quite it was
quite cramped together looking about now
you know the office was pretty small
actually really yeah I think back to s3
now and we move them to a much bigger
office and you know you got all these
kind of grand memories or whatever but
that office looking back was pretty
small and you kind of sat on top of each
other and everybody's up on their feet
it was it was cold I was kind of hooked
yeah yeah so obviously got that job and
then to frame it up then so you spend
what four years just like five years
yeah five years there's a real solid
stint for your first not not very common
that yeah right
so just a framework for everyone so
spend yeah just under five years at s3
and then join energized right and was
there for what for and the boy is four
and a bit years and then after that set
up obviously Oakwell and this business
been going out for four years four years
yeah okay cool so very quickly then so
the when I looked on your LinkedIn the
stuff so there's sort of typical did you
just take the typical route s3 sort of
climbed up the ranks yeah did that yeah
so was your gorilla and I've really good
I'm not going to sit here and say yeah
you know that was one of the best or
anything like that wasn't do you confirm
software development
yeah run-of-the-mill c-sharp developers
okay but yeah I think I think consistent
mmm-hmm you know I think I could be
relied on to to help out with team
targets and stuff like that definitely I
believe I'm a better manager than I was
a biller
guys gonna say did you want management
yeah from from day one I think naturally
my skills aligned to that yeah I think
looking about now
there's better billers then I go back to
the main kind of crooks of that office
there's better bill is that me
definitely
management I think is where my main
skills light okay so just two things
that I'd be keen to just ask you about
the s3 experience one so when I moved
out to London and I started working for
oxide this is when I got exposed to this
whole sort of s free brand chaos outside
of London didn't anything about it so
well how would you describe the
environment obviously so many a lot of
people that a lot people none the real
criminals free successful people come
out of that business so how would you
describe looking back that environment
and yeah how much of an impact do you
think it had on your a huge impact
massive impact mmm
and what was it like it's it's so
competitive really yeah ultra
competitive but you you we we only used
to hire grads right so you had this kind
of mentality of of people moving either
to a city that they didn't know so their
friends were all also new to pavement
and worked in the office so you end up
being mates with everybody yeah but you
trying to beat each other but then
you've got this brand versus brand thing
that was bigger s3 thing that's changed
now from from speaking to people now but
the brand thing was huge right so
progressive we were always wanting to be
Oxley wanting to be yeah view works for
progressive aggressive yeah so he's you
kind of like competing with each other
on a daily basis and then suddenly
you're you're a team again could you
trying to be helpful it was just yeah
just and did I encourage you then to not
want to be at the bottom of the pack you
wanted to strive for the best you wanted
to be at the top of the best you trying
to be yeah the weirdest thing is like
when you when in that era anyway you
didn't know about anything else outside
or outside of s3 why would you want
that's the crazy thing now I think isn't
that like yeah I can have that light you
just know what's with the going on
within your four walls you yeah that's
it it was that that was and they just
did it so brilliantly well that you
wouldn't want it was almost like you'd
failed if you did leave mmm that's what
it was like
you know kind of took you this hard to
get down sorry it was that difficult
kind of getting the job in the first
place and then difficult building your
patch and now you're in it and they've
got these fantastic holidays all these
brilliant Christmas parties all this
kind of stuff you made your mates there
honestly it was like right if you leave
it's because you failed yeah and you
know that's not necessarily a positive
thing it was it was made that way I
think I don't know if that was
intentional or what but it worked and
looked really really top five years I'll
learn an awful lot and it sort of final
thing on that I think thinking on people
listening maybe working in bigger brands
or grown businesses like how one what
would you sort of put down to you being
able to because as you said really
competitive so why why do you think
indeed got the opportunity to progress
get the management positions and these
types of things as you said maybe wasn't
the best biller compared to some of the
people around you but why do you think
that you managed to get there
- go ahead of some of the the
progression and opportunities think it
was consistency it was key you know you
got people who can come in in six seven
eight deals in a month and then blank
for a few months and that kind of thing
where I think the consistency was key
there but then as I said it's it's when
you get that opportunity to go on team
lead to start off with having you know
taking the training training
unbelievable as well then putting into
practice I think having that common
sense of ability to just work with
people and understand people's
motivations and things like that s3 was
always one of those which were trying to
build here at Oak well as well is that
it's a meritocracy how well you do you
go through and it always felt that I
never felt like it was there's a ceiling
or anything did you proactively seek all
you want to deserve because I think that
people can typically expect like given
it was it was so clear what you had to
do really yeah so that's a big fat -
right but clearly it rain clear yeah the
amount of companies people you speak to
now where you know when you're
interviewing people and they just
genuinely don't know what they have to
do to get to the next that's alien to me
I didn't yeah that's been working at
anything right yeah yeah that makes
sense
okay so then and failed and left energy
[Laughter]
so obviously I've obviously as you know
had have one of you had Jake on the
podcast yeah what they're obviously
they're quite big Brandon manager as
well aren't they growing yeah so so so
work then and did you again it was that
did you go there straight his manager or
what was the wedding will to grow the IT
part of it which when I got there the
company was was pretty small think it
was six fifteen sixteen people something
like that yeah and the company and given
that progressive Manchester was that
twenty six or something like that yeah
it was strange for me yes but not like
you know good four years there as well
you know opened up so now something like
fourteen fifteen different markets for
them grew the IT side of it and the
digital side of it and so that's was
that is that what you was really good
that when he was working for other
people which I'm sure you're doing for
yourself now is open up markets building
teams yeah
hiring the right people to do that with
you know with you and training him the
right way and making sure you taking
advantage of the opportunities that are
out there so that when I left for
energized it was a good market as well
we've just come off the back of the
recession so things were picking up
really well as well so it was I think
the great thing about joining a small
business like that at the time was that
it was a bit of a blank canvas for me
which was which was really nice actually
looking back because you know they were
trying a few things I'm coming from a
huge s3 background where I've been kind
of drilled into what what you can do
what works right so you've have that
anyway so you put all that into practice
straightaway and then also then put in
your own ideas on top of that mmm so you
know something's going to work first of
all then you just adding these little
things on top to see if they work or not
and that was the one thing that probably
being s or you couldn't do you that
businesses they knew what work but it's
huge but they weren't agile yeah you
know you could if you wanted to change
something you could change it to in this
really small degree but then you have to
answer to someone as to why you've done
that whereas going to somewhere as there
was 1516 people we started whose you
could change anything within
you know he was he's all on you which is
great and you know we use a good four
years mate so started out quo with two
other two business partners started
we've been straight away and then Simon
joined after six months just with
confidence and everything had you always
wanted to do had you always wanted to
have your own agency you are in business
tied to the idea in the past as be
actually wasn't so there's never been
like kind of more what definitely
definitely one of my own business but he
just seemed like the right time mmm and
it's one of them I think we were talking
before about sometimes you think all Now
or Never
man that was that been to be that was
that because you were saying obviously
that yet you'd say since Santa business
had two children yeah so around the time
you decided to start the business what
your your wife was pregnant no no we
just got married okay
yeah I mean perhaps not really timing
started the business 16 out of first
child in in seventeen and then had my
second child
last year so I've not slept for four
years base how did you meet your so how
did you meet your business partners was
it through the hire them both here oh
really okay so did you had so how much
of a strategy did you guys have um we
had a strategy obviously look we we all
we were already doing what we were what
we were going to be doing yeah you know
so it was can we grow this ourselves
so first of all you know it the time had
come to leave yeah right so when I came
to that conclusion the loyalty factor
from Ben and Simon was huge they said we
want to come we want to be part of it
fantastic call and then it was about
right doing in the right way so we knew
what worked again and we just set about
doing what we know works first of all
growing it that way and then being so
always being open enough to let
different ideas and I think that's why
we've grown quite quickly its we know
what works great that's your call and
then just let a few different ideas here
and there yeah
interesting how happy are you that you
started to other people
massive yeah huge I said when you when
you take II personal life everyone's
gonna have different circumstances I've
had two kids in that time Ben's got
married another kid in that time Simon's
gonna get married now it all your
personal life changes affect work
obviously so when you've got you know
people you trust to just count on huge
what so let's break it down and so oak
well-being it's so it's been going for
four years now
how were the first years but how was the
factory so was it just use it just you
free for the whole year or say it was so
mean Ben started it and we'd strike oh
yeah and yeah Ron start training
February trading in February sorry
we hired three people within the first
month really by the end of March sorry
really
yeah how can we decide to hire people
because I you know I don't add oh yeah
right did you get what did you get let's
get people's exactly well part of that
strategy you know most people say right
you start a business you got you
everybody get on the phones but whereas
I thought right where's our strengths
lie all right been really Billa and I
said did you or did you know each
other's strengths sliced from day dot
you know that fair yeah that helps right
yeah I think sometimes people need to
wear that out then they will work that
out but we knew because we'd work
together for so long that mice you know
hire the right people trained them was
my job get them you know performing
quickly and Ben is bringing clowns
remember we you know as a director my
all business I had six months well can't
touch any business that we we've worked
with over the last six or twelve months
or whatever it was it sort of been just
had to start over start from scratch
here picking up the phone absolutely was
it the obviously not the same clients
but similar sort of market or the market
decide to niche down in any way or tech
markets do what we know do what we know
is successful what we're good at I'm
sorry and then grow from there really
okay so first year then just in terms of
like headcount what did that look like
again do you one we finish the headcount
wise I think we were on not eight maybe
people say yeah okay how how did you get
a free people into the business mate to
join their free chat
it's a question I get a lot from people
yeah and I'm sure you hear it all the
time like you're part of networks and
the power hive of things like this like
and obviously businesses really struggle
to get past that scale from five people
to ten people to 15 people etcetera so
yeah how did what was the sales like it
was that's probably one of the biggest
achievements we had office which was
tiny I mean it fit five people with
eventually we somehow got seven in there
what was the cell sorry what was the
cell what the cell was right this is
what I've done in the past yeah this is
where we're going and be be an early
entry into that recently and you look
you're not in it I'm saying I'm not
gonna but we are we had two people never
done recruitment before really yeah and
one person who'd been working a truly on
saw a very different type of recruitment
what we were doing and you know all of
them did really well to him in
particular did fantastically well over a
hundred grand one of them one of them
hundred grand first year second the
other guy then did 130-140 second year
yeah it was you know decent decently
core that we had doesn't that wave and
then that mastery house near because
that's what that's people struggled to
get that sort of call right and it's
perm as well so you know the kind of
cash flow was was quite quick what why
do you think why do you think I was able
to achieve that in a first year it was
look you have to be able to train people
right I know that was you that's not
saying like a while no no no but no but
you said you know what your strengths
are and your sex was to get Mack get the
best that you can absolutely yeah it was
much better for us for me to dedicate my
time training coaching developing and
hiring the right people and letting them
go in the market so we knew what work
than me potentially getting back on the
phone and trying to points press I just
naturally interested view think of a
typical small business especially if
you're a solo founder or small business
typically they wouldn't have the luxury
of not having to bill and just focus on
their people do come in so that's a huge
asset it was huge it sleepless nights
right yeah yeah it's not that makes it
any more easier but I think that's the
fact that you as
the founder of the business you could
just focus on right got these three
people in the business
let's make less set them up for success
yeah yeah no investment either hmm was
that so purposeful or did you think
about it I mean we we had savings a
little bit so he means that we point I'm
not sure how much runway did you give
yourself I think a lot of people think
about that how he should one finger
about starting recruitment business how
long should I give myself in terms of
yeah so don't I'm not [ __ ] my pants
about taking on three people
straightaway right yeah so we we started
making placements immediately that was
the big thing
and I think our second month yeah ma I
think is March or April first year we
did something like 25 grand a head
really yeah for billa's just yeah I was
just under a hundred grand in that month
and it was like Fair Play right okay we
can do this yeah that confidence and I
said because it was because it was
permanent payment a seven to thirty days
in between there it was it was coming in
quickly right live fantastic and it just
it just went from there really
okay and then and to copper final things
on the first year mate one did you have
any soil plan or strategy to sort of
make your recruitment business different
yeah what was that everybody - from what
I can remember that you're talking about
external candidates and clients and how
fantastic you need to be phlegm of
course that's true of course that's true
but we the way we recruit in our
industry it really depends on how good
your consultants are so everything that
we did it was about employee centric
first so if you can treat you hire you
train you treat and you keep the right
consultants and make them Baron Baron
pair internally first they're gonna then
go and do that
good job externally so that was it well
we mind that when we create a culture
where people want to join us and then
not leave because from there then
developed this this training program
this progression path that you know what
over the first not to 12 months it's
about just getting better and then we'll
see the results after that and a lot of
companies will give people that
at I'm not news I'm good yeah exactly I
would like oh you mean yeah yes so is
like right we've got three months we've
got six months we've got 12 must know
exactly what they after doing that time
if they're doing that it's not nothing
to shout home about but if they're doing
that they're progressing and then you'll
see a huge spike from 12 months on and
that's exactly what happened that's
really interesting so that was the
typical length of a period that you were
the mindset was to really invest in
these people and good mature if they
didn't obviously the right things in
between the activity and the Nansen
let's come from the previous four years
and enjoyed the previous five years
progressive as well just every one I'd
ever managed anyway going back and
analyzing how long it took people to get
going that was it if you if people could
hit the milestones that I gave them in
that first 12 months the second 12
months were always going to be pretty
what were the mustangs make sure the
first three months is about growing your
marquees no there's nothing new here
it's about growing your market hitting
certain things then it's about a little
bit of performance then it's a
consistency once you've got that then
you're ready to go was that so you know
networking first of all making sure that
you can rely on cancer and kind of rely
on certain clients start getting some of
the rewards for it and then making sure
on a monthly basis you're being
consistent and everything that you do
I've got also being cool enough to say
look if you're not hitting those it's
not going to work out you know I mean so
one thing that when I speak to people
let's say like the hive that that were
part of this struggle with letting
people go really they're too late or too
early
okay so but because there's no real
parameters in them that they kind of
just go in a well I think just on the
cusp of doing something well or they
left all too quickly or they get on with
that person so they want to give them a
little bit more time or whatever is what
asked the way we do it here is a little
bit black and white and try not let too
much emotion coming to that because what
okay if you know they hit those
parameters then you what so just to be
clear I think that's great just to be
clear for everyone listening like war
those parameters I mean cuz I think
that's what people in here right it's
like okay in do that that's that's great
really good advice definitely couldn't
agree more cuz I've had those
conversations yeah when people saying
that's a struggle and stuff like that
but so you said firstly Mumsnet work in
one development yeah market yeah but
what the just clear parameters we're
like you know what if this person isn't
doing this then yeah I know that it's
putting on the workout yeah okay the
first three months that say it's about
net you so we're growing your market
first of all right so getting new
clients winning clients winning jobs
head on in candidates you know doing
that the the central parts of the job
that if you can't do you're not going to
be successful in it then the following
so once that's ticked off the certain
you know kind of numerical looks like
law outside terms as sine terms its jobs
meetings that kind of yeah that you know
intrinsic or thing really the next three
months after that is about finding
performance now so can how many offers
you gain in that time how many
placements are you making in that time
how many you know certain pieces of key
performance indicators you get in that
time so how well are you covering a job
how well are you getting out one
candidate to X amount of places and then
the following six months from there is
about doing that on a consistent basis
in place so you know one thing what I
don't like necessarily is somebody going
and gone through five placements in one
month and then blanking for the next to
take the five placements I mean but you
want to make sure that they know how
they're doing it and its consistence of
the cycles you know come in three four
week cycles at the absolute latest so
once they're into that routine its then
starts go right okay and no I can do
that and I'm comfortable doing that now
how do I get the best out of it and
that's where predominately we've seen it
comes to about 10 months to 12 months
yeah yeah okay year one then biggest
challenge would you say because it seems
like yeah light up she got but there's
some people that you got in they did
really well business partner just
netting it from day one
and if a business partner follow you
said I did the same what words would you
say were the biggest challenges here one
would you say my biggest challenges you
know no one's none of us had run a
business before hmm so everything about
that really yeah yeah this is stuff you
didn't know just stuff that you know no
one really tells you too much about yeah
you know it's the honest review the
first year when
really well yeah really well so you know
when you hear these horror stories about
you know how they're gonna pay their
staff didn't I think we didn't have
those problems it was more about the
other things in the background that you
need to know and then actually one of
the biggest learning curve I suppose
rather than a difficulty was that I was
trying to recreate something that's
already being done is through not trying
to recreate it to be a thousand person
company but trying to do things in the
same way but it's no you need to just
use those experiences and do in your own
way well you know there's five or six or
seven of his in a small office and we're
all suited and booted and you know I
mean in Manchester at all our clients
are in London like what why are we doing
that yeah and and what actually one of
the big things that we do is like once a
year twice a year whatever we get all
the consultants to tell us what they
really think is going on how they
happier than not in a real kind of open
conversation one of the first things I
said like why on earth that we wearing
suits really yeah and it was really
difficult for me to let go that's yeah
but yeah one of the best things we've
done and looking about 9yf what we do
and we do a client meetings you're at me
in candidates or whether because we're
based in Manchester predominately and
most of our businesses is down south we
know when we're gonna be meeting people
right so you - hmm
let's think about that for a second so
then what just to sort of frame out then
so end-of-year - did you continue to
vest of see yeah
focus on your people and then bring some
more people on yeah and a journey yep
yeah what did you end up in I think
actually what did you what did you end
up doing billions revenue was year one
yeah one turnover wise was about six
hundred okay and then water so then what
going into year two what was the plan
there's a lot right guy actually like
you elect each other like no what we can
do this yeah what's because now I'm sure
yeah got a bit more confidence on
but a confidence we'd had a lot of
confidence in sa hiring the right people
and them coming good and then we started
to see that that not working as well you
know what there are people you know and
that's that's down to was of absolutely
our interview process before I needed to
to evolve but it was more the same - Lee
yeah another good year good growth both
on and on turnover and and size of team
really our kind of difficulties if you
want came when we got bigger really yeah
you know we've been as high as twenty
seven twenty eight heads I think at one
point and scaled that back a little bit
just because at that stage I'm sure
you've probably seen different companies
when you get to that stage you need a
lot of people performing you can't
really have too many that you variance
tougher and we've moved office as well
so we were in this absolute what hit and
the fun yeah so we were in and off it
we're in a building which I've walked
past him and just a million times before
I never even noticed it yeah nevermind
kind of thought oh that's office space
hmm so we're in there for two two and
three years and then we came in to this
place which you know fits sixty people
altogether sixty sixty-five people so
this is gonna be a headquarters for
quite a while mmm but with it comes a
huge cost to it as well coming out to
where we were so it's just about kind of
taking that next step mmm and one of the
big things was realized and look you
know profitability wise and everything
else it's probably not going to be as
high as the first couple of years even
though that seems slightly bigger and
revenue and turnover his eye but I costs
have increased as well I'm not being
scared of that you know when it's we're
not trying to sell a business right now
we're not trying to secure investment
right now anything like that it's about
you know growing it growing in the right
way enjoying yourself while you're doing
it so as long as you know everybody's
happy we're growing with we can with
with you know kind of financially cool
as well then that's that's the route
we've taken mmm
and you know we'll see we'll see you
continue to grow I'm sure the next
couple years
okay so just why don't we just and very
quickly just break down the sort of time
before you decided to as you said not be
scared of investing the place like this
back back in your cells well actually we
are going to grow this is the plan what
so you mentioned that the part some of
the challenges were the the hiring piece
right hmm I think so many people obvious
the most ironic thing and the right
right yeah I'm sure it's an ongoing
process ongoing journey oh he's becoming
a bit more slick as you said just having
just getting even more tight with those
parameters and knowing definitely you
know how that person happy grow off they
won't be but what what were what did
what did you sort of change in the maybe
interview process or what did you start
to include or your sort of
non-negotiable was when hiring that you
think that's had an impact on get making
a better decision that's such a common
challenge but yeah yeah yeah well as I
said one of the biggest things that we
did right from the start was having an
all inclusive culture yeah hmm so one of
the the key things we did was get a
larger proportion of people involved in
interview process okay and we've said no
to a few people that I probably would
have said yes - that's interesting
where you've got some of the guys and
girls out there yeah yeah yeah you know
we can go into an interview situation or
or a drink situation or whatever that
may be and pick up a few things where
the interviewees let their guard down a
little bit and you know brought that
back to my attention 11 and you know
we've made decisions off the back of
that so and you know that we've been
burnt a couple of times where somebody
has come in and you know they're not
culturally correct for what we're trying
to do and you can see it straight or
when you think how have I missed that
and it's probably because of which so
constancy driven in that particular
point whereas somebody else could have
come in you know not nice
did not just be in relying on your
opinion or you and Ben Lord yes when you
so small as well it's so important yeah
you know yeah I remember when I've got
the when I went instead of chrimbus I
went in so I think on that four people
one of them being owned in the freer a
bit less yeah
and that's also yeah okay so then yes
that
that's interested so yeah other people
may see something that you don't yeah
oh so that gets a bit difficult I mean
there's yeah as well is that you know
when you set out how did you get three
people to join a business that right so
obviously when you go an interview
situation I'm selling it as hard as I
can and sometimes that's not right for
the other looking right now is they're
gonna come in and maybe I've sold
something that isn't quite exactly as
they envisaged it now and whereas when
you get some biller in to tell them we
encourage them to say look what's and
I'll tell them everything that you need
to tell them you know what's cool what's
not what could change the truth
absolutely honest here and then they'll
know I'm probably surprised that much of
a long way that goes huge market yeah
the thing is it's back to what you said
when these two come up a comment songs
where when you're wherever you are in
your business journey and you are a bit
small or whatever you're part of you a
guy that I interviewed recently
Christian shared this luck when he was
earlier on in his business he was a bit
light I'd be really grateful if they
join me just because of like where you
are in the journey yes there's also an
element of you wanted to sell to them as
part of light Niall ever hopefully
they'll join those sort of things you
know yeah you know that first year I
remember interviewing a few people and
they're saying they're interviewing here
they're like whoa why are we even doing
in this yeah he's like alright then but
then I start realizing I'm a hiring
someone because they were interviewing
at x y&z and and it's a kind of yeah it
is us to have our kind of gone over and
and and done something because I wanted
to beat them rather than actually
wanting this person yeah I mean yeah you
know those kind of lines got confused a
little bit at times and again strip that
back and make sure you don't do that
again
but um yeah it's it's a minefield right
it should be really easy period so for
you then like on the just as we're on
this of and hiring for own business
tangent like for you what are the
non-negotiables you look for little
critters for your business today I'm
sure they're unit to you and your
culture but for you when you're looking
at people for your business so like
what's the model that you've gone from
sure it's a bit of an expert gingy take
on grads take a mix it's a bit mixed
yeah so what were the non-negotiables
when when hiring for your business
they've got be congruent so what I mean
by that is what they say they have to
back up okay half T so you know the
easiest example is people send her money
motivated for example and they've gone
through uni gone through college all the
rest of it never had a job just like
what you are you talking about
I I look for things that either somebody
has has you know kind of either done or
or in a situation that they've found
themselves in and they've got out of and
in a positing a real positive
environment and impact or they've found
themselves in a bit of a negative
situation and turned it into a positive
I like people like that who have kind of
had to grab something you know by the
scruff of its neck and turn it around
and then just somebody who can who can
really kind of explain properly
succinctly what their motivations are
and why a lot of people don't know that
anything today they do if you can dig
down enough mmm because you can tell me
that you can do go and don't talk to
somebody and they just don't know why
they're why they're there and they don't
know why they were here needs to be able
to do that if they can't that's what I'm
saying if they can't if they can't
describe it and they can't explain it
then and why is that why is that
important because you've got to know
what you're aiming towards yeah yeah
this job is kind of be monotonous kind
of yeah day in day are we doing very
very similar things you getting ghosted
by a client or a candidate or you can
like see left right and center sometimes
you have to then remind yourself why
you're doing it so if you don't know in
the first place you struggle yeah and
then how much of them how much does it
helped you because you've been quite
visible online I think that's fair to
say
has that been a conscious thing
celebrating success you know fefe you've
done that like purposefully yeah I'm not
in like an egotistical way but you've
constantly you wanted to let people know
that the milestones people hitting in
your business and it's not not for
external purposes what you mean it's not
that you where you fight if I put a
LinkedIn post up saying congratulations
to X why's that because they've been
promoted it's for that person
yeah so it's not like I'm not trying to
say look what we've done
yes it's it's for that person I find
that nowadays with a younger workforce
that they the social media element of it
is huge so how much does that how do you
massively because I think that people
happy you know they're happy with with
that kind of that visibility for
themselves externally it helps not for
my cars has helped the size it has it
helped you make cause for your business
yeah I think the the biggest thing it's
done is I says it's it's helped the
culture here people know that they
they're getting rewarded with with
really small things putting a poster
because somebody's being promoted or got
being consoled a month or something is
the easiest thing to do in the world
right but it shows that we care mmm when
I was a recruit
if you got consulted you didn't do
consultant if you got a couple ideas get
pat on the back in a and a pint maybe
right whereas I think now it's just that
it's so competitive and I think
motivations have slightly changed for
you know in the in the world that we
live in now so that kind of recognition
yeah that recognition is quite important
yeah and I'll just interested just
because I think if I look at a
Fivefinger I spend a lot of time on them
LinkedIn and if I see you and your
business I think quite I think quite
easily I can get a bit of a feel as to
what it might be like to work here yeah
I just feel like that's obviously
helpful when there's have many religion
businesses yeah just relying I mean yeah
it goes back to your initial question
you know what we did we think we could
do differently and it was it was very
simple and plain to see that everything
is about attracting the right people to
work for us you look at our website for
example it's it's more about was and
it's more about people to work for us
than it is necessarily for clients and
candidates now people might think that's
wrong and I've been told it's wrong
quite a few people in the marketing
world yeah you know we are potentially
adding things onto that but you can see
that we've gone after it trying to
attract the right people to work for us
and I think we can get that right
internally first the next ten it'll just
work and has done so far so
okay what I'd love to hear from you mate
is a bit about hiring triggers from a
business standpoint so as I said a lot
of people message me or interested in
India how the hell did you go from yeah
five people in that sort of not so big
room to where you are now right so some
people may think that's just impossible
for them or not attainable so have you
had you have you got better at or have
you sort of picked up or noticed it's
not gonna be played for all the time but
sort of I don't know making sure that
you the people that you do have in your
business right now or at a certain point
then you go right okay we can get to
three more people in now or just just
noticing or getting better at when to
hire or getting new people through the
door yeah I think data's huge I think if
you if you're not using statistics and
data to do that you go in an emotion a
little bit you feel like all the team
might need a bit of an input let's get
someone new in or we need to get rid of
that person now because we've had a few
bad months or whatever
I think date is we use cube 19 right
alongside ball on and alongside a few
other things sauce breakers or better
mention them in case there but cubes
been the one for us which has been so
simple so easy to use and tells us
exactly where we're at any one time yeah
and then when we start the businesses
said it was when did you invest in that
Tom Wensleydale say three years too late
I think it was about a year and a half
ago two years ago now so that's had a
pretty big impact that served an impact
definitely because as I said it tells
you where you're right but when we start
the business you didn't have data so was
you know we had three people and then
the next person next person on the basis
of it seems to be going quite well but
you can't yeah but you can't keep doing
that yeah so but we now know exactly
their cost base exactly cost per head we
know exactly how much we need to then
make profitability wise not that we know
about data we know we need to do that on
an XYZ basis so that will then trigger
the next hire and then we can do that
for pair team and we can also do that
first of the each sales manager as well
so each sales manager knows what they
have to do performance wise on a
three-month basis before that next one
I often ask what that's that's exactly
one and to ask that and I guess again I
know what changed for different markers
and stuff but what I sort of put on you
duper man contract then yeah so I know
it would change of stuff but rough cost
per head that you're looking at getting
a team at for you to then consider right
okay let's maybe consider getting
another person watching New Berlin we're
still quite lean which is good business
so we're we're kind of looking at a
revenue of between ten and twelve K per
head and that's over a period of time if
you yeah that team yeah that will then
get the trigger it's not like I they're
done twelve they're done twelve K on
average over the last three months let's
get lights over a period yeah like for
now for average but sorry for examples
sake if you've got one of the team
leader sales managers out there has got
say a team of four they're looking to
get to around about 50 grand from those
four people on three months in a row and
you get the trigger that's interesting
yeah so and and as you said data can
massively help that helps because you
know if you if what can happen and
without it without data you cost
conspire without you knowing yeah or
your cost versus what you're bringing in
isn't correct
mmm-hmm yeah I mean just gives you more
confidence in the whole decision-making
yeah exactly and they just make better
decision-making for sure and have you
always had the men what's been your
mentality towards have you always had
the mentality of light
I'm always hiring as in like are you
someone or have been like quite reactive
rather than or have you always been the
person in this business that's
wouldn't to go for a coffee with someone
or would you not i mean what sanity to
that quite plant but then as though
because we've got these you know the
trigger points and and when we can hire
so to speak but I'm always open because
if you've got somebody who's good that
comes along then I think being small is
one of those where some people go wrong
isn't it they're just make it can
sometimes be a bit more reactive and
when I've sat down when people never got
more actually the my sort of role is
well actually I'm really focus on
growing the business on someone that's
always sitting down attend your hires I
think the probably the problem being too
planned suppose is that you're almost
saying over this small
dough is one we're gonna hire hmm so you
can only get the best at the at the very
best you're only getting the best who's
become available yeah exactly yeah so by
just being open enough that all the time
you hope you know you hopefully will
come across some really good people
mmm this pros and cons again for grads
and for experienced people of course
well there's no right answer there I
don't think
well we've had some fantastic
experiences with experienced people and
not all right and as I said you know one
of the the guys that we we hired
initially he wasn't even a grad he was
just a sales person worked in a bar and
he was great for us so it's just a man
thing about recruitment
ya know there's no background yeah okay
so what what did you how where did you
get to in terms of porn is a business
for you to decide that you're gonna
invest an office but it can fit what
triple the amount of people you is that
what was that for is that fair yeah how
how yeah how and why why why it's pretty
easy we sat on top of each other you you
know you could make a cup of tea wash
your hands and do a phone call probably
so we needed to move yeah and what
answer where was you as a business
before you said you know chat was like
we need to look at as in so as a
business we're just for everyone listen
so before you went into this place which
can fit 60 65 people whereas you're out
of business so he was at headcount wise
we were at 18 I think 18 yeah okay and
then yeah I'm assuming then and then
what have you done revenue wise out here
anything because I'm sure that must have
been the big factors to go you know what
let's invest in that I think we were
just shot two million really yeah from
from memory yeah so it was it's a big
move mate to be honest here because as I
said the office space itself was was so
cheap so really really hiking cost of
the overheads really have increased yeah
because we're now smack-bang
literally yeah middle when I first came
here to meet you I was like [ __ ] our
light it's lychee in yeah I mean I'm in
understand there pretty much yeah
a bit better yeah I mean it's it's
Dean's get one side yeah you know I
wouldn't say on the square it's it's
pretty expensive and it's pretty big so
it was a big decision but it was one of
those where it felt right you know you
walked in like rock a call this is the
next step and it'll be the next step for
a while if you know so we needed to move
that was obvious we were doing well and
then you know kind of the one thing that
was really holding us back
so when we first started I was something
to do I'm interviews in a hotel because
I was a bit like really yeah I was like
how am I gonna but then as you as we
progressed into that slightly better
want a bigger anyway should we say
office we had one meeting room as well
but you had to walk past everybody to
get into that meeting room so it was
just actually putting people off to be
honest with you yeah so it was becoming
a necessity to what we would do in
performance wise and what we were
portraying social media wise we had to
now kind of back up a little bit and be
very very real in that respect as well
so this place came along with that yeah
old phrase times right mmm okay and then
and then so you've been in this place
for the last yeah and then that's when
you've quite a bit see now what circa 25
you said to me yeah roundabout that yeah
okay me and I mean during during this
time you're building the family yeah
building the family they kind of dictate
really but yeah how's that been when
you've been trying to build this
business man I think I will always
enjoyed about yeah talking about revenue
and all these things but this is real
[ __ ] that people go for it right you
says massive health business partners
yeah as you said you under you said you
didn't sleep but like how how have you
juggle both how is that being for you
I'm not really sat back and thought
about it I might cry no I love me
obviously my wife amazing you know she
takes a 99 percent should we say off you
know daily duties should we say um but
let's give you an average like this
today yeah today so weirdly out of the
blue you doesn't do it anymore
my little little boys he's nine months
old it's called that and he wakes up
after 1:00 this morning for no reason
right normally sleeps all the way
through great f1 bang up crying for an
hour right cool half plus two I can't
now get back to sleep I'm moving around
loads gonna wake my wife up so I go to
one of the spare rooms McCall in the
spare room
can't get that sleep last time I look at
my watch it's like quarter to five right
quite a set no half six my daughter
comes running and dad wake up call half
6:00 right really trying to have a
breakfast in there both he's climbing up
my lady's crawl in now she's like wants
to have my breakfast yeah so then you
run out trying to get the train get to
work works manic obviously always is and
and then I'm getting a train but I'm
legging it from here to the train
station at five o'clock so I've got to
make a call plus five so I got to get
back to bed time bath time bed time
which is just nuts yeah and then you
kind of sit down around about eight
because I have somewhat to eat yeah and
you might have a bit of a conversation
with your wife but then she's absolutely
sure she's going to bed and it starts
again the next day right [ __ ] you now so
the air that's been going on for for
three and a half years now really three
years and then how have you I mean one
obviously there's neither option right
like this you know I mean there's no
other option besides you obviously yeah
making it work but how have you some of
the things that maybe you could share on
how how do you think you've ensured that
when India walks through these doors at
your top of your game and because when
you're here it's no longer about the
children it's about your people right
yeah yeah so like how have you insured
that you're the best you can obviously
you're gonna have good days and bad days
but how have you insured the top of your
game for everyone around you the
partners
yeah so being great as well Ben and Sam
that's a Ben that is his first child as
well and he's you know he's in similar
boat really but also the trust I have
marked maximum trust in and the people
without so it's you obviously got to
make decisions and then that data helps
right so you're not using emotion you're
not tired one day and you're gonna make
a weird decision are you
really happy one day because you slept
and you send that mate when you have
those things it's very clear if people
were cracking on with what they're given
that that makes you a bit more calm like
yeah yes a lot of people I can imagine
have their own recruitment business and
what they are worried about if I don't
have the day so they don't have the
visibility of [ __ ] is is Jake in the
office doing what he's meant to be doing
right yeah but you there's like that no
it's that help that's help yeah exactly
it's but trust me yes better you know
we've just recently launched work from
home you know a couple of days a week
yeah not long ago a couple weeks ago
what time and just felt right really yep
and what people been asking for it or
did that where did that come from you
say it felt right but did you pull it
out we've always been flexible you know
people need an hour here now are their
hereafter or whatever but I think
putting it in now it just felt right in
terms of just the way the workforce is
going and again you know we want to
attract the right people you know we've
got all the things that you need to be
able to track how well somebody's doing
how much they work it doesn't matter
where where people work from necessarily
we do try and keep a culture office wise
cause I think that's important
especially for juniors and need to learn
etc but having you know a couple of days
flexibilities is I think the right way
to go and then on top of that we also
launched something where everybody's in
a part ownership of the business now
really yeah yeah yeah so what so how
have you structured that so if we put X
amount of percentage of the business
away and I've given an employee kind of
scheme in that way was because like
they're kind of goes back to your
question a little bit about you know how
you've got all these things going on at
home how do you and how do you make sure
that you're the best you can possibly at
work well I think if people own it
mm-hmm then what you know why would you
want to do about job if you own anyway
yeah I mean so we purposefully doesn't
that we've launched it everyone seemed
to be happy
hopefully and you know let's see how we
go from there but it was something that
I remember reading or listening to a
podcast myself from I think it was Simon
the Foss yeah oh yeah yeah yeah I mean
that was really when we first out the
business and really struck home with me
really struck a chord I was like that's
a that's cool as long as you can tailor
it and structure in the right way yeah
and then you know then we had to see how
the business worked we've got the right
people have we got the right culture is
it working
once that was kind of like yes is then I
was always working on something to try
and bring this in yeah and how do you
exactly structured it is it okay for you
to share that or like I'd give you some
basics on it yeah because I think the
reason why I'm just asking and curious
about that it's just because I think
when when people hear equity like I
don't know there's kind of quite a bit
of smoke and mirrors congi a lot of
people like yeah you know I mean there's
there's definitely that cynical yeah so
like how yeah how have you
yeah the what the basics of how you
structure and how yeah it's gotta be in
in with us for a year before you become
shareholder yeah and it's all about each
well everybody in the business is
working in the same way to grow the
value of the business and to get it to a
certain point at that certain point they
will receive either a bonus worth what
their their shares are worth or if there
is an exit or if there is some kind of
died out aware that maybe they also get
it then but it doesn't have to be and
yeah okay that's the part yeah yeah I
think that's where a lot of people are a
bit naive or unsure like didn't didn't
realize well actually I know and I don't
really get I can't really get any of
this unless something happens yeah
that's prevalent everywhere in the
industry is now I've been in that
situation myself where it's it's a bit
pointless because you're not in control
of it and if
if the company never sells or didn't
even use its my butt and obviously said
in their Ryan Adams mmm so yet obviously
did a podcast of in recently and and
three months or four months always it
might be in July we started business in
July then in October so he had chair he
was a shareholder in the console
partners and and they sold the business
for like nine or ten million or it might
even be more in October yeah but he'd
left started on business said zero
shares yeah similar journey to uh
suddenly Ryan he's obviously not in
America now because he's kids and yeah
yeah we spoke about that but that's
really interesting then so and how and
how long ago was this sorry that when
you implemented this all offer this
we've been doing we've been working on
it for six seven months now and we
launched it started yeah well and how
have you noticed has there been a
difference in this other than I have you
picked up on anything where she's been
interested in or I think just behavioral
mmm yeah I think you know yeah I think
it's I don't really know what I would be
looking for yeah yeah a cyst but I think
a certain certain behaviors have
definitely changed and you know I think
people now are also aware that they're
aiming towards something and it's I
think the biggest thing is knowing that
once X is hit it doesn't matter what we
sell don't sell records they're gonna
get that payout as a bonus basically and
it's it's structured its structured
really well if a thing if I was a
consultant I'd be well bought into it
which is cool so yeah it's it's
definitely added that's wicked that are
feeling that's obviously one of the
great things about being around business
right but you can offer offer things
like that to the people that helping you
grow this business Yeah right exactly
yeah that's what I'm saying one of the
biggest areas of development for me was
trying to actually go after and do with
my own ideas and rather than as five
years s3 was unbelievable in everything
that I know from those guys right but
then it's kind of a double-edged sword a
little bit because you're almost so well
versed in doing it that way
and I don't know any land you don't
trust yourself a little bit but you
can't create something that's already
been copied something I don't think
because the best version is we have been
done and then you start looking at
eventually anybody looking at things
thinking well what's the positives up in
a really small business now rather than
having that huge business in the late
2000s when I joined a we're not mean and
it's like being being small being
flexible being agile yeah having your
own ideas implementing them and seeing
where they go trusting yourself yeah you
know that's all the things that I've
probably learned more so than actually
the intricacies are doing the job which
have helped more yeah and the exact and
that's one of the that that's really
interesting yeah so you found yourself
sometimes falling back into knowing what
works and yeah that's interesting so
okay so the let's just think about the
the last year for a second
yeah so and as you said kind of right
now a sort of 25 heads what did you do
revenue wise last year mmm
turnover was just shot three million
yeah so let's talk about that for a
second spoken a lot about people that's
really been your focus and clearly a big
partners to work how you've got to where
you are so far like how how do you think
you've enabled or being able to achieve
that growth you know I mean what are
some of the key things there yeah good
retention yeah that's a good you know
good good consultants that we've got and
we've got good client base now we're
trying a lot of different methods if you
want off of trying to make sure that a
client retention is stronger and a
client client you know kind of building
out the clients that we've already got
is strong and we're not just
continuously going after you before all
the time contract has helped an awful
lot this last year was that all I
investment last year when into contract
really yeah a lot of it as well to try
to do that because I think where we want
to go we want to get it to a 50/50
company that's a year both in the UK and
in Europe we started in Holland now as
well so that's the V any of the
contracts in the UK and
which I offer if I've gone in place good
decision I'm not sure but I'll say
Holden that's where the investment came
in so contract help at loss a lot last
year and just the other said earlier on
the the progression path that we have in
place a huge amount of investment in
people in that 12 months a couple years
ago is now really paying dividends
so that's been the biggest thing how
much how much time or how much do you
invest in retaining your people that few
many people like focus on that and not I
think you might be really honest with
yourself that's I think that's the key
thing you know how many you know you
speak to people all the time now right
how many people lose an employee and the
first thing to say is what he's crap
anyway yeah yeah I mean like was he
why'd you hire him them why'd you hire
and it's yeah I think you've got it own
it you've got an own own the decision
you've got it own if it's a mistake and
you've got to then understand and really
look into and think well why is that
happened and if that's one of the key
things that we did and we can we
consistently do always lose that kind of
benefit absolutely yeah hugely I think
just to sort of run off because I think
again that's definitely gonna be a
challenge for a lot of people but why do
you think you've been able to retain a
lot of your good people no I think the
recognition part is cool yeah belief we
straight through no speed cameras type
of progression so they know what they
have to do to get promoted what's the
typical career path that you've sort of
structured for people out of interest
not similar to most people's that offers
a junior rookie you know go through the
consultant path so it's consultant
senior consultant sales manager business
manager managing consultant director
like and then you've got your principal
root as well so I'll shoot director that
way but they can be quite quick
progressions is it is it typically done
on what just buildings or demonstrating
against your values or have you
typically measured that from that's one
thing that I'm so yeah look we're kind
of normal should we say in terms of you
know you've got a bill Exum how that's
normal birth in my
no I know so what I'm saying is like I
struggle because I said to you early
dose you know I was a you know an
average to good recruiter um you know
but a better manager I believe and I
think more people can go down that route
but in recruitment it's almost like what
you've got a any stripes first of all
because why would somebody yeah listen
to you kind of thing so at this moment
I'm we're very much down the normal
route of yeah you've got a you know the
buildings is a is a target competencies
alongside that other things come into
play as well depending on which company
working for right but I think the key
thing for us is it's quite quick and I
think that's what I've seen as well
again with it with a slightly younger
Millennials or whatever age group we're
in now I don't know but quicker
progression is is key I think so not
necessarily you know making it easier
for them but having maybe more
milestones in place and they feel like
they're progressing yeah I think that's
really important that's interesting and
then final thing they again I may have
sort of cover this but I think again you
could give some really good insights how
how do you think you've got the you just
spoke about keeping your people but and
then make it maximizing people in your
business hmm
so do you do all the training still or
how do you think of what something to
keep because again I think that's where
some a lot of people fall short is
always thinking about oh I should
probably get someone new in to do this
or someone get someone new in and could
change this like how have you as you
said that is first twelve twelve months
really important but then after that how
have you maximized and ensure that your
people were just the best that they can
be and if in that you've done that yeah
the consistent training is that
something that you do it both yet
internally I do a lot of it we have
external trainers as well management
structure in place and so that's been an
organic growth as well which is cool so
you know managers are well versed in how
we do things and then you know that has
that core is in there and then they're
putting their own spin on things as well
which is good
and then as I think the biggest thing is
that everybody knows what they have to
do to get to the next step I know you
sit down you and that is key yeah
absolutely the clarity reading clear and
clarity yeah and then and then the other
things we've talked about you get the
interviewing wrong you're off to a
you're off the Quran for in straight way
right but you can get that right what
the motivation is right you got then the
clarity of how they progress correct
then the joining a business that they
want to work for culturally it works for
them then they were well invested
because potentially in in 12 months time
they're going to be owning a small
percentage of it all that has helped us
get to where we're at right now and got
an awful long way left to go it's a
couple final things met before we finish
just on that what as you as you said
started and I'm cs3 and these sorts of
things like what what do you think of
this sort of real common traits that
you've seen then sort of really high
performance in your business or in your
time now and the last sort of four say
is that may might be slightly different
than when it was compared to when you
started like what are the common traits
that you've seen in highly successful
billa's people around you yeah I've been
the traits when I was a bill that was
got to work hard like not like you don't
work yeah but it was phone based yeah I
mean it was really kind of heavy on the
phone yeah get out speak to people as
much as you possibly can make things
happen that way and I think the from
what I've seen the top bill is wise now
is that you've really got to be in your
network really in it my parlor yeah 100%
you know getting out to as many
different events as you possibly can
using social media to your advantage and
adding a hell of a lot of value rather
than just hiring a person that's that's
the key thing I think we the difference
I think if I look back I was quite a
transactional retrouver I really enough
to say that but so were hundreds of
other people and you working for working
alongside me and maybe that was no I
didn't do as well as a but I think now
if I look around certainly my office and
look around some of the other off the
businesses that I know around Manchester
there are those good builders and good
performers are really well versed in
their marques they really know it you
know whether clients are bought into but
that's the adding value piece it's not
just hiring some
before them they really are contributing
to that business I come in so knowing
what you know now anything that you'd
say to yourself at the beginning of this
Oakwell journey or would you'd say to
people that might be early on this
journey knowing what you know now just
trust yourself trust yourself yeah if
you if you've made the decision to go
for it you've done it on merit right
you've done it for a particular reason
you think you can do it so trust you
talk did you seek any help early on like
from other people that some help - sorry
come up a lot so yes I mean that the the
network group the power hive has been
great for us unknown and look you know
Sean runs it he was my old boss Keith
runs it he was his old boss so we've
known each other a long time anyway but
even knowing them I didn't reach out to
them you know that's mother yeah crazy
um you know and why do you think that is
why the lie it just you wanted why I
don't know if there's so many people you
just get on with it
yeah I didn't you just kind of off you
go and then as I said it's just trust
yourself I would say and use the ideas
that you have in your mind definitely
going back to your ideas yeah rather
than trying to copy something that's
already being done yeah but yeah if you
know people which invariably everyone
who starts an agency knows a lot of
people in the same industry seek that
help because I don't know if there's a
thing where you think who I'm gonna give
away some ideas and then they're gonna
get a competitive advantage on me or
some finish line so ridiculous is enough
for everyone right so yeah yeah ask for
help
definitely and what was the war the
subtle growth so you've gone into the
year 5 now yeah yeah or four years old
yeah
what what what the growth strategy is
sort of from what you've learned like
anything that like anything you're gonna
do so clearly again really focusing
internally but they're different things
you're offering stuff like that but how
what yeah how are you planning on the
scaling or growing the sort of year from
what you've learnt now yeah so the
investments going to be in the teams
that are performing obviously yeah got
those triggers in place so that we
talked about yeah we want to go into
European you know in a big way and we
started off in one ago we started off in
Amsterdam yeah and it's it's looking
like shall we say a very very
by a market some big fees in there and
are you all in the UK predominant
predominately yeah both in London and
the Northwest as well but yeah that that
Dutch piece at the moment is looking
tasty should we say yeah just the way
that we recruit perhaps is well versed
to how they like to do it so far
but we see some good room how that's
been the strategy on that just like if
you've got something that's done it
before or is you just sort of toss
someone that was up for the challenge
and just not to open up a market there
or talking to people first of all as key
yeah and they were so forthcoming in
giving that advice as well thinking you
speaking to one of them Chris stringer
yes who's an ex colleague of mine from
progressive days okay yeah you know he
was a just do that market yeah exactly
and he was he was great Dan door Moria
you know they were cousin moribund do
quite a bit of that yeah so in Bell
invaluable advice early doors removed
that top builder onto it okay and say
you know he's he's making a real fist of
it at the moment just cool I want to get
more people into there because why do
you want to do that to diversify where
you represent yeah yeah yeah and you
know the UK is great we've done really
well out of it but you do get squeezed
on fees it's loads of competition as we
all know and yeah ultimately we want to
diversify across Europe one and I do
want to look at the states at the right
time but we still want to keep that core
in the UK as well you know not gonna not
gonna kind of look to turn that away
most is my home and another for fun from
others field yeah and got a couple
questions for you on resilience because
I have another event in mum and the
podcast going up all about resilience
and going the distance but and before
actually those met what what are you
excited about me what you're gonna shout
about what my excite yeah yeah just in
life business what were you excited
about well i excited up well we're
hopefully going on the league this time
yes that's pretty cool big yeah
definitely know that
don't care don't get time number one
it's a rubbish excuse number two tickets
are ridiculously difficult to come by I
went now to watch the kids play
Shrewsbury you did that
yeah it's I'd love to go more was that
okay I'm excited about all Kwame I'll be
honest with you you know I think that
we've got a really really good group of
people here and we've got a massive
opportunity to take advantage of a good
market still at this moment in time I
believe contract is going to be
interesting over the next few months
definitely but I'm excited about the
diversification we've got going on and
there's some as I said this it's just an
exciting time for us as well because you
can really feel that the company is as
one you know everyone kind of moving the
same direction as well good so I'm
excited about that and obviously from my
home life it's exciting times as well
yeah okay so I've got three questions
for you what what does resilience in
recruitment mean to you
means not giving up but don't make the
same mistakes they asked very well
present yeah I think some people go edge
don't give up and and just knocking your
head against them and how do you think
the importance or needs for resilience
has changed as the industry's evolved
I think you know like you asked the
question what was different ten fifteen
years ago to now and I said the phone
base versus being in your network right
the phone thing resilience was not
getting annoyed not getting pissed off
when people tell you to get lost and now
it's I think the resilience wise now is
more in the internal thing where it's
about can I can I keep going in terms of
networking can I keep going in terms of
right I wanted to do three placement
system I've only done two it's that I
think it's a different type of
resilience when the before it used to be
just go again just go just go again and
I think this is and I think as well just
the the the landscape of the the social
media where we live in as well it's just
comparison comparison comparison people
with something that's not true right so
I think that that plays a big part in
resilience as well all the you know
forget I'm not talking about Instagram
as to plan I'm literally talking about
LinkedIn where one recruiter says this
well maybe I should be doing that as
well or they've done really well there
should I move across there or I think
that that kind of resilience are just
looking into early first before I'll
just keep on going where you doing what
can people do themselves to instill
resilience in their teams so they can
what can people do themselves to instill
more resilience in their teams I think
break targets down yeah I think a lot of
everybody else targets right as they
should do anyway in the sales
environment but sometimes I think just
you leave the target as the end goal
yeah and I think that that's where you
break it down yeah absolutely
because that can help with the
resilience landing in there you kind of
just taking that step you yeah you
taking the step by step each time you
can celebrate each step if you want to
and I think that would help you last
question cool you can answer this with a
sentence a phrase anything that comes to
mind mate
so if indeed could communicate every
single recruiter out there every single
cream a business owner they'd listen to
you
take on your advice implements it
tomorrow what would you say to the
people may look after stuff yeah yeah
just seriously look after it's it's one
of mental health is big isn't at the
moment in time should be big all the
time we do a really stressful job and
across the industry across just you know
people not in recruitment we get a
really bad ride and I think it's our as
company owners and directors and
managers it's our kind of jewy to make
sure we look after people and office
yeah a hundred percent
not that my in this been a pleasure No
thank you man Cheers